Transcription: Irina Sinenkaya
Relecteur: eric vautier
J’ai appris qu’il y avait
des milliards dans le porno.
Du coup, j'ai décidé de me lancer.
Pour ça, j’ai décidé de choisir des
parcours traditionnels des entrepreneurs
et j’ai même pu bénéficier
d’un accompagnement de ma région.
Durant cet accompagnement
on m’a appris à faire un business plan,
à voir que finalement, je n’avais pas
le droit à des pépinières d’entreprises,
à l’ACRE,
en fait, tout ce à quoi d’autres
entrepreneurs avaient le droit,
par exemple, des aides du CNC.
Ça ce n’était pas possible parce que
c’était une activité qui est stigmatisée.
Pour ce qui est d'ouvrir un compte
bancaire, il faut savoir qu'en France,
depuis le 13 juillet 1965, les femmes
peuvent ouvrir un compte bancaire.
Mais les actrices porno, toujours pas,
alors obtenir un prêt pour une
entreprise porno, on n’en parle même pas.
Ensuite, pour ce qui est
des évolutions législatives,
maintenant la loi impose
des contrôles d’âge
pour vérifier qu’il n’y a pas
de mineurs sur les sites.
Sauf qu’on ne nous propose pas
d’outil concret pour vérifier l’âge,
tout en protégeant les données privées.
On parle quand même là de
données extrêmement sensibles.
Ensuite, pour ce qui est de la diffusion,
diffuser sur son propre site
n’était pas possible pour moi,
du coup, je me suis tournée
vers des plateformes.
Mais il se trouve que les plateformes
n’ont pas une très grande liberté
quand il s’agit de la diffusion.
Leurs contenus sont pour la plupart assez
lisses, alors que moi, ce qui m’intéresse,
c’est plutôt les représentations
de pratiques BDSM,
de pratiques assez kinky.
Mais j’ai quand même pu
organiser des tournages,
et sur un tournage,
je me suis posé la question :
« Comment j’aimerais que ça se passe
au mieux pour les acteurs ? »
Avec mon associé Robyn Chien, on a décidé,
plutôt que de plaquer nos fantasmes
de réalisatrice sur un acteur,
c’était de demander à l’acteur :
« Qu’est-ce que tu aimes faire ?
Tu aurais envie d’être
représenté comment ?
Quelle image de toi
tu as envie de renvoyer ? »
Et à partir de ça, on a construit un
scénario et on n’a pas été déçus.
Il se trouve qu’il aimait
être représenté comme un chien
et on a pu faire
un super scénario de puppy play.
On s’est éclatés.
Il n’avait pas du tout envie
d’être pénétrant et c’était parfait.
Si je me suis posé autant cette question,
c’est parce que, lors de mon premier
tournage professionnel en tant qu’actrice,
il était vraiment question du consentement
au sein de la représentation.
C’était une scène hétérosexuelle,
et il fallait absolument que ce soit moi
qui commence le rapport sexuel,
pour bien montrer au spectateur
que, attention, je consens.
Par contre, pour ce qui était
de mon consentement à moi,
le tournage ne s’est pas bien passé.
C’est-à-dire qu’on m’a fait signer
un contrat, pas un contrat de travail,
mais une simple cession
de droit à l’image, le tout en anglais,
et ça venait d’une société estonienne.
Autant dire que niveau respect
du droit du travail français,
on n’y était pas.
On m’a imposé de dormir avec mon
employeur, ce qui est juste inadmissible.
Ensuite, au moment du tournage,
j’avais une scène le soir,
on m’a fait attendre
toute la journée dans le froid,
et quand j’ai négocié pour pouvoir
juste aller au chaud dans un café,
on m’a dit que j’étais capricieuse.
Bref, vous l’aurez compris, il y a
certains facteurs qui favorisent
les violences sexistes
et sexuelles dans le porno,
et le meilleur allié qu’on peut
avoir pour lutter contre ça,
c’est le droit du travail.
Il est important qu’on ait des contrats,
qu’ils soient envoyés en amont,
qu’il y ait une grande transparence
sur ce qu’on veut faire,
sur ce qu’on ne veut pas faire aussi,
et que ce soit respecté
lors des tournages.
C’est pour ça que beaucoup de productions
ont mis en place des coordinateurs,
des coordinatrices d’intimité,
pour veiller à ce que le consentement
des acteurs soit respecté.
Je pense que ça se passe
aussi dans l’après.
Je pense que l’acteur doit avoir
un droit de regard sur le montage
pour ne pas avoir de mauvaises surprises
parce que c’est lui qui est exposé.
Si je m’intéresse à tout ça
et si je vous en parle aujourd’hui,
c’est parce que, je l’ai dit,
je suis actrice porno,
je suis réalisatrice,
je m’appelle Eva Vocz,
je suis aussi chargée de plaidoyer
sur les droits des travailleurs du sexe
pour l’association Act Up-Paris,
et je pense, sincèrement, que vous,
vous avez un rôle à jouer pour faire
évoluer l’industrie pornographique.
En fait, en tant que consommateurs,
parfois, je suis désolée,
mais vous êtes un peu passifs.
Vous avez tendance à avoir
une consommation efficace
et si on veut que l’industrie évolue,
il va falloir que vous soyez
un peu plus actifs.
C’est-à-dire ?
Par exemple, dans la grande distribution,
on a vu que du jour au lendemain,
il y avait beaucoup de
rayonnages bio qui ont poussé.
Ça s’est fait parce que les consommateurs
voulaient plus de transparence,
voulaient des produits
de meilleure qualité,
voulaient une plus grande
diversité de produits.
C’est pareil du côté
des consommateurs de pornographie.
Je pense que vous pouvez, par exemple,
vous tourner vers des festivals de porno,
vers des plateformes de porno
en accès payant.
Faites-vous un petit peu des défis,
essayez de déplacer un peu
vos habitudes de consommation
et vous allez voir,
vous ne serez pas déçus,
parce que changer de consommation,
de manière de consommer le porno,
ça a des bienfaits pour vous,
pour votre sexualité,
pour penser le rapport
à son désir autrement, pour se dire :
« Tiens, telle pratique je n’y aurais pas
pensé d’emblée, mais ça me botte bien. »
Je pense que c’est important
de prendre du temps
pour se questionner sur sa sexualité.
J’ai une copine qui m’avait dit que
le porno, c’est toujours la même chose.
J’ai demandé : « Tu regardes quoi ? »
En fait, elle va tout le temps
sur le même site en accès gratuit,
elle regarde tout le temps la même chose,
et elle s’étonne de tomber
toujours sur la même chose.
Je lui ai demandé : « Est-ce que
tu vas dans des festivals, etc. ? »
Et en fait pas du tout.
Le porno, je dis le porno, mais
on peut parler des pornographies,
il y a une grande diversité qui existe.
Et si vous avez l’impression
de voir toujours la même chose,
interrogez-vous plutôt
sur vos habitudes de consommation.
Je pense qu’il faut aussi se questionner
sur la manière dont
on consomme les journaux.
Le porno dans les médias, souvent,
est traité d’une manière assez
caricaturale, assez stigmatisante.
Je vais vous donner quelques clés
pour savoir si un article
est orienté ou non.
Par exemple, est-ce qu’il y a
des acteurs et des actrices porno
qui sont interrogés dans l’article ?
S’il n’y en a pas,
c’est plutôt mauvais signe.
Est-ce qu’il y a des représentants
de l’industrie pornographique
qui sont interrogés dans l’article ?
S’il n’y en a pas, c’est qu’on s’écarte
de plus en plus des réalités de terrain.
S’il se trouve que
ce ne sont que des politiciens
ou que des associations qui sont
anti-porno qui sont dans l’article,
ça ne veut pas dire
que ce n’est pas une vérité,
ça veut dire qu’il y a
un point de vue qui est biaisé
et qu’il est sûrement orienté pour vous
faire penser d’une certaine manière.
Ce que je dis là, sur le porno,
c’est valable pour tous les sujets.
Donc développez votre esprit critique
et ça nous aidera à lutter contre
la stigmatisation de notre profession.
Pour finir, je pense que
la dernière slide est très claire.
Je pense que vous avez un rôle à jouer.
Vous faites quoi ce soir
en rentrant chez vous ?
(Applaudissements)